[Aplausos]
à noite é obrigado pelas nossas
presenças é encontrar aqui um pouco no
percurso profissional e entre as regiões
o dia não começou muito vai e vai poder
ouvir ao vivo com bóia e para a
apresentação do cantor como é viagem e
crescimento da zona de conforto
eu não estou habituado a falar em
público no momento estou à frente do
computador e uma zona que não vai à
vontade
o trabalho é eu sou ilustrador
cartunista o trabalho de um pouco da da
imagem sem palavras e entendo sempre no
meu trabalho cartões ilustração
empresários e os próprios os próprios
imagens com precisão um compromisso com
o mundo através do design da minha
credibilidade e fazendo um trabalho
[Música]
muito intenso e tenta acompanhar o
retorno de notícias da aids correm pela
internet
tem sempre uma ilustração para fazer
sobre algum tema mais polêmico é a
terceira e talvez até mesmo sobre algum
assunto
faz quatro cartões assim cartoons sobre
o mesmo tema é isto
vamos contar um pouco do meu processo
criativo ea umas histórias engraçadas
pelo maio e uma delas vai passar porque
eu estava num na casa de um amigo meu e
do juiz estava vendo tv e no rádio
eu vou à conforme rivais no facebook
tenha havido os atentados e de repente é
uma coisa que eu sinto quando acontece
alguma desgraça no mundo tendo logo
começar a criar formas de comunicar
através do design e curiosamente irá
jantar entre no fim de nove cursos até
casa eu tenho uma idéia do tamanho do
estado entre na cana e logo nessa
madrugada surgiu logo uma ilustração
alguma idéia e fez no quarto que publica
no quarto novato guardian eo piloto foi
acionada na manhã seguinte com esse
trabalho como não fiquei contente já que
o trabalho persistência da minha parte
fazer design e contava ora como eu quero
que cada trabalho
no sábado a caminho de um necessário
para uma bomba de gás desde gasolina e
fui ajudá lo e tirar os irmãos dos
diretores do jornal e as jornalistas
através do fórum tocar no produto
primário que vai premiar a ilustração e
de assassino menos ponderam que teria
utilizado nem colocava isto para dizer
que a existência eo acreditar muito no
trabalho criativo e de estar atentos à
política nacional
o acusaria e principalmente o que se
passa no mundo sempre fazer o meu
trabalho criativo e depois tentar vendê
lo e vendê lo hoje
hoje nas revistas porque há um trabalho
a um trabalho de anos disse acreditar
que estimula e que faz com que o
trabalho
eu entrei em contato com vários
diretores de jornais
listas e etc o tempo tentando vender
notebooks a crise - é sempre lenta manhã
com os atentados em nice do caminhão
eu estava num concerto e clipe quase
como uma espécie de missão no meu
trabalho e leva pesado de casa minha
vida pessoal e largar tudo para ir pra
cima do papel e e naquele momento
surgiria procurar idéias para 14 para
ilustrações
eu estava num super voto e assistiram a
concertos e de votos forma que os mais
atentados em frança e saia mas o
conserto e do local de trabalho e fiz o
mesmo estressado também foi capa no
expresso online e entrar em contato com
o diretor da árvore a seguir e assim não
funciona às vezes levo logo ter uma
intervenção como design isso tem que se
pratica no meu trabalho tem tido alguns
trabalhos
salvo alguma forma com sítio lá fora e
eu fiz um cartoon que o círculo sem os
observarem observar pelo militar
e um em maio eu fiz um trabalho sobre a
síria
foi um trabalho que o inspirou eu queria
apresentar apresentar o que estava a
passar na síria e uma idéia sobretudo os
principais atendimentos
o tiro de guerra e lembrar um deslizar
um trabalho de picasso guernica
como é uma guerra
eu queria que fosse imediato o impacto
visual e design
lembro do trabalho
as personagens que vai pura fazer um um
trabalho inspirado no veículo picasso e
alteramos o grupo tem nova no cavalo
mais para frente vocês vão ter a
oportunidade de ver
é isso trabalhou inspirarem e então que
em caso de ficar no nosso trabalho
porque foi o que de alguma forma me
trouxe até aqui por uma viagem com um
vinho com um cowboy preparar a atenção
também a pensar que fosse convidado
papel e eu pensei que era levado um
trabalho intenso nos últimos nos últimos
tempos e que determinada altura muito do
meu percurso de vida
os cartões 800 páginas as eleições nos
estados unidos
e eu fiz uma série de deus porque na
outra casa ser uma pintura ea própria
hillary clinton também os seus pessoas
clínicas acaba por surgir isaar e maciel
- é bom ter um trouxe muitas idéias e
pelos visto infelizmente o roteiro vai
alterar a apresentar nos próximos anos
durante a viagem que tinha sido
convidado por trás do computador e que o
resultado do seu trabalho de parto no
que faço regularmente constantemente
ilustração de livros para crianças faz
mais claros
eu felizmente num tem vários registos
mais aptos consoante as necessidades dos
clientes e depois faça esse trabalho
autoral e que tem publicações nos
jornais e nas revistas e nos media
internacionais
isso é sobre a sentença de morte do
filho dela
também trabalho faz oura sobre a
sociedade num
aquele segundo um trabalho de primeira
linha do papel
depois é trabalho nos as instruções do
computador
há sempre um trabalho de design de
assento na assembleia geral da portela
esap resultado final ser digital tudo é
desenhar coisas que dizem directamente
no computador do coisas que eu faço hoje
em dia uma mistura no início quando
vocês ganharam de conteúdo fazia tudo
normal e pintava jornal hoje em dia
também os clientes também nos obrigam a
ter uma rápida e exige uma resposta
muito rápida e isso também é muito
rápido e precisamos só de velhos só
tinha criança voltar um pouco que o
trabalho a ser comunitário lo por vários
jornais da imprensa nacional e
internacional
de repente ouvi uma quinta feira esse
item o trabalho que está a ser visto
humanitário desde assim é até o brasil
estados unidos todos os jornais da
imprensa internacional
partilhar a 1 mantém se uma entrevista
com o jornal inglês e dois diretores do
malote que partilharam as suas páginas
esse trabalho fizeram referência ao
ilustre do português e das pernas como
tem muitos seguidores se tornou se viral
nenhuma percebi soube através de outra
pessoa é uma editora do jornal público
para que eu comigo e com quem vamos
parar várias vezes que não tinha piso
que estava a passar e na quinta-feiras
quinto 120 jornais para publicar em
trabalho na dinamarca suíça uma
entrevista ao canal al jazira que vai
pensar no final do ano minha
apresentação e e de repente vão mesmo
turno 11 não acreditar nesse sentido e
trouxe muita visibilidade e também
alguns conhecimentos um trabalho foi
inspirado no picasso e crianças mesmo
quando surgiu daí eu queria acertar
decidindo em casa dos pais tenham uma
réplica pequena do governo nessa sala e
talvez tenha sido por isso quando lembro
de uma guerra civil na imagem vai lavar
a cabeça esse trabalho picasso e que
apresentava naquela situação e fazendo
na atração e uma transformação pra a a
situação na síria
eu não sou diferente através do design
temos sempre passar uma mensagem seja a
forma como é óbvio
eu sinto que há uns que são mais fortes
que em outros álbuns que fazem rir
chorar e os refugiados como estamos a
viver aqui alguns cartões sobre o tema
das migrações e dos refugiados é um
assunto do processo juíza não fosse por
esse motivo não eu não gostava disso
todas estas coisas são coisas que eu
sinto e simplicidade do despertar alguns
momentos quando mais de 16 sobre as
sessões e tentar procurar trabalho além
dos jornais e das revistas pelas redes
sociais têm um papel muito importante no
meu trabalho na divulgação e difusão do
dos cartões que tem feito o time
engrenou certo é uma coisa que eu tento
ver se acontece alguma coisa num num
numa noite entre o nuno de assis tem um
trabalho sobre esse assunto e por vezes
até lá os trabalhos que tem em mãos para
fazer um cartunista alguma coisa que é
quase como se fosse um vício e leva a
ter sempre uma intervenção com o
trabalho que já estamos são trabalhos
relacionados com a síria
aqui uma eu não falei do meu percurso do
como é que tudo aconteceu e eu tinha 18
anos precisa um indivíduo que estava no
secundário 30 e mostrador e também
queria ser pai e criança - ou seja os 40
anos professora zenaide verdade é com
esses jogos realizados e engraçado
porque o povo aqui um percurso que eu
passei no deserto e continua a lutar de
fazer pelo tempo de vida esteve aqui é
uma altura em que não tinha trabalho
esse foi o trabalho que estava a falar
em cima do avaí no cavalo
lázaro é possível a união européia que a
maioria dos refugiados e as freqüentes
atentados
e foi esse trabalho e acabou por dar
alguma visibilidade a cnh global e
surpresa apenas uma virose a brincar na
área das redes sociais
depois de analisar dos sírios todo mundo
não só entrar no ataque e até foi
difícil escolher daremos também presa
dentro de casa desde os outros trabalhos
sobre o seu lugar na síria também teve
no twitter uma conversa com 16 eram dois
turistas mas foi foi foi uma situação
assim um pouco desconfortável e que
deixar de repente fui bombardeado entre
aspas por mensagens desagradáveis disse
que o problema está em outro vídeo da
entrevista nos ensina
esse foi o filme do canal 10
vai ser como uma coisa
[Música]
eu com seu pai tem um filho de 5 anos
tem visto imagens horríveis e que de
alguma forma não ser seguro então para
ter uma intervenção como design
[Música]
queremos pôr o governo putin
apresentação do doutor representa a
força da guerra é termos uma mãe com uma
criança na sofredo dos bombardeamentos
em guerra
[Música]
não sou de ferro não conseguirem de
frango ea única coisa que eu sei e posso
fazer é através do design chegaram a
passar uma mensagem especial mas sempre
né
[Música]
[Aplausos]